[Applause]
you were just bringing up f1 yeah uh did
you see the race no i am not an f1 guy i
know you guys are but it seems crazy
please enlighten us is what happened
okay so americans found myself included
found f1 from this netflix show drive to
survive correct and they film this
netflix reality show after the season
and everything's all said and done you
already know who [ __ ] wins you ever
know who wins every single race and they
still find a way to make this world
incredibly interesting and compelling
right it's almost like um i don't even
want to say it's friday night lights
because friday lights was scripted like
you actually didn't know who won or not
right this you know yeah but they find
the drama within the drama it's like a
really i can't believe people like it
like it'd be like watching like the
highlights from like the nba playoffs
afterwards we did
what last year yeah i guess i guess i
guess the greatest team ever yeah
jordan the greatest athlete ever yeah so
we're like all right i want to see what
this is about that's true yeah and it
was also like uh there's like nostalgia
like you're watching a christmas story
or something like that like how do i
relive those feelings that i had [ __ ]
two decades ago true right but where
this is literally what happened
three months ago it's like you know
everything that happened right and it's
still so [ __ ] good and i think it was
just so new to us we're like okay i have
to relive this and i guess you get a
little bit deeper into the drama et
cetera so this season of drive to
survive should be absolutely amazing if
they fumble this opportunity that they
were given right now then take the show
off on netflix they're [ __ ] idiots
who are producing this show it is
quite possibly the best from everybody
i've spoken to and again i'm late in the
game this is the best formula one season
that has existed in
their their lifetime
i mean everybody's like people come to
you i've been watching since 2001. i've
never seen anything like this
right so maybe in this generation of
racers okay maybe if you're coming back
to like senna and those guys it's a
little different but even then maybe
there wasn't the same level of drama
obviously those guys were dying and [ __ ]
it's crazy basically
for for everybody who doesn't exactly
know what's going on the formula one's
not fair right it's like baseball okay
okay so it's like kind of like unlimited
budgets it used to be more limited and
then every year they go oh they were
going to find a way to do like a salary
cap kind of but basically the teams that
have a lot of money can throw money at
the product right okay like we're
talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars right i
mean mercedes might spend half a billion
dollars on their team was it 300 to 500
million dollars okay so the big money
teams are mercedes and red bull right
and
uh they also have like other teams and
supply like red bull has a whole
different team that's also red bull
alpha towery right and mercedes supplies
engines to other seams it's a really
weird thing right doesn't matter formula
one's crazy and uh this year max
verstappen is the kind of like lead
driver for red bull and then lewis
hamilton who is the greatest of all time
won seven championships uh with mercedes
right he's going for his record eighth
right this year
red bull comes on strong in the
beginning of the season then mercedes
comes back
going into the final race yeah they're
tied in points
so whoever finishes higher not even
first whoever finishes higher wins okay
the race happens
hamilton starts in second place okay max
what's happening on pull right so he's
hamilton
gets the lead okay okay
he's left out there on i think what is
it hard tires right
so mercedes makes a decision not to have
him pit because he could lose placement
right right but the risk is he'll be on
worse tires right right he's in the lead
he's winning he should win the race the
race is about to be over i think there's
four laps left it's over lewis hamilton
won he got his eighth it's done
this guy latifi
nicholas latifi
crashes with four laps left right okay
now with a crash you have to remove the
car
from the track right okay
when you remove the car from the track a
caution car or a safety car goes and the
senate surely leads all the cars so it
limits the speed that they can go nobody
can pass etc
okay
four laps to go
depending on how long it takes yeah to
get that crash car off the track right
the race should end yeah in other words
if it takes four laps that's the order
the cars are in that's how the race
finishes yeah
right
with one lap to go
they get the car off the track so
technically they can race for one lap
now lewis is in first max is in
second but he's in fifth in terms of
position because there are cars that
have been lapped
okay those cars are called lappers right
generally speaking i think when a
caution car the car leading the group is
out they let all the lappers go around
in this specific one they didn't think
that they would have enough time to let
the lappers go
massey i think his name is michael
massey
makes a call this is the guy who like is
the the the race coordinator the person
who's making all the rules
ray stewart is that what it's called
okay
he makes the decision to let the cars in
between
lewis hamilton
and max verstappen
lap in other words go in front of the
caution car essentially getting them out
of the way
so there can be one lap left of racing
but he doesn't let the other cars behind
do it okay so he's basically just like
move everybody out of the way there's
one lap left for the championship let
them go
now here's the thing
max is on the fresh tires yeah he's on
the what are they called
he's on soft tires huge advantage right
right
remember because uh mercedes made a
strategic choice
to
keep lewis on the field for position
right red bull had nothing to lose they
brought him in they put in the soft
tires because they're like listen we're
already five spots behind the worst that
can happen is we get set and you can't
pit when there's a safety car taken they
did pit on the safety oh and they said
but louis but mercedes didn't want to be
as they might lose position okay so like
we'll just keep position so it's the two
of them now i've heard different uh
viewpoints on this one viewpoint i heard
is this is like you're playing your
buddy one on one and it's a game to
seven and you have six and he has zero
and then
somebody just goes okay next basket wins
right and it's like whoa what do you
mean next basket wins yeah i got six
yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on you just moved
all the people out of the way now would
max have passed all those other cars
yes but they would have caused uh at
least some kind of delay delay
difficulty
milliseconds who knows i assume you just
you got to move around them and also
keep in mind in a in a lap in this
course and in most courses there's only
a couple places to pass right it's not
like
right you need enough straightaway to
develop speed yeah right and a turn
where you can come inside yeah so let's
say there's only three places per lap to
pass and there's two cars in between
getting rid of those two yeah
if those two are in the way you're
[ __ ] because that you pass you pass
races over getting rid of those two
gives you three opportunities to pass
one guy and i'm sure i'm [ __ ]
bumbling this and i'm getting certain
things wrong blah blah blah it is what
it is i mean if you have any corrections
of what i said if there's super f1 fans
out here you know that i'm more or less
learning about this now but i think this
is pretty much what exactly happened and
so in that
max passes lewis
first place
wins
that seems [ __ ] it seems [ __ ] now
here's the thing the sport's not fair
yeah we're not we're okay with the
unfair rules and the second the unfair
rules disadvantage the team that takes
the most advantage of the unfair rules
they're upset mercedes spends hundreds
of millions of dollars more than every
other team to have advantages
yeah a rules put in place that put them
at a disadvantage not even a rule a
decision was put in place to put them in
a disadvantage and now they're whining
and crying they're not whining and
crying about the fact that they could
spend double every other team yeah this
[ __ ] ain't fair the sport's not meant to
be fair it's meant to be entertaining
yeah right and the rules are created so
it's entertaining that's interesting
right it's called the constructor's cup
we look at these things because we like
athletes in america we're like who's the
michael jordan who's this
the way formula one is looking at it is
which team what mercedes still won
right they still won the constructors
cup max won his championship but
mercedes still had the best car right
and it's about the best car because the
reality is you could put
a decent driver in a mercedes
and he's a good driver they're going to
win
okay they had a guy from the worst team
i think it was williams uh andrew
russell's george george russell who's
getting 15 16 plays consistently in in a
mercedes car but not the car that's he's
in a williams car that has a
mercedes-benz mercedes right okay races
one race
when lewis is out with covet or
something like that
races one race in a mercedes
leads the whole race is gonna win the
race and all of a sudden something
happened to his car right um
oh [ __ ] and i think what they did is
they protected lewis yeah because
they're like if this guy who's getting
16th place every single race all of a
sudden pops into the mercedes and then
he can win it all in one room oh that
might tarnish
lewis's reputation how great is lewis
yeah
is he great or is he in the great car
and this [ __ ] is all about the car when
you're at the upper levels of driving of
course if we're already looking at the
top one percent of drivers
you put in like a new qb on a team
you're like oh is it the system or is it
the qb yes yeah it's the system yeah and
the qb can take it there yeah but a
system is right i think you're bothered
as a fan from a distance it would seem
like i'd be bothered just because it's
like all right well these are the two
best companies like you said these are
the two best car constructors so at this
point let me at least make that as even
as possible
sure eighth place could be in first
place if they had more money but first
and second which is what we all want to
see let's make that as even as possible
let's not [ __ ] eliminate cars and
give them another advantage when they
already got the same financial we can
blow everybody out the water yeah let's
just see them go at it fairly then yeah
as fair as it can be yeah it seems like
that [ __ ] with that that's why i'd be
bothered yeah yeah i could see that is
it standard for them to remove the cars
um during that yeah safety oh that's the
standard yeah
they have to be as if it's just there
during the rest of the race
not the [ __ ]
talk about the lappers is that was that
a standard move every race that they
would remove the lappers yeah but i
thought i think that what they do is
they let everybody pass
yeah and they only let the lappers
that were in between lewis and max yeah
so if they're doing something just for
this race it feels fair yeah yeah but
the guy said it because the guy total
wolf who's the uh the basically the head
of mercedes he goes he goes what the
hell are you doing and then uh the guy
michael massey who's the steward just
goes
we came here to race today
what these team principals have been
saying let them race let them race and
mercedes just because of their influence
has gotten a lot of favorable decisions
this season yeah just in particular uh
to uh louis on max and this is something
that hey so if you're a real fan you're
also probably satisfied like [ __ ] you
you finally got everyone just say like
this was great for the sport yeah yeah
yeah i mean it was unbelievable
unbelievable does hamilton benefit on
the back end that the sport is now
getting more eyeballs
yeah of course of course like how mad is
he really like obviously it affects his
legacy and money but like oh this next
season is gonna be insane i'm sure he
wanted eight yeah like you want to be
the guy that has the record if he has
eight and that's one over schumacher but
he has the win for most races
record for most uh racist ones yeah he
has one round and him and verstappen
have a bit of rivalry right not even
like verstappen's a new up-and-coming
driver like lewis has been it'd be like
it'd be like uh jordan and kobe having a
rivalry yeah but like in the moment have
a bitter rivalry okay in the moment they
were talking a lot of [ __ ] about each
other this year
no lewis is pretty mentory to to him oh
really yeah this season's just been a
battle but in the last couple seasons
and i realized something with the
netflix show
to your point it's not even for us
anymore it's for the people that are
gonna say listen to this podcast and say
i'm gonna try out formula one yeah start
it off by watching the netflix stock
then you'll be watching the next season
you'll be obsessed in real time and
you'll be obsessed i i've got i got
through almost the first season and then
i wasn't obsessed was definitely a good
show but they talk about verstappen in
season one you can basically if you
watch the show i've realized watch his
whole arc from like kind of brash punk
kid that's got a lot of talent into now
winning the [ __ ] thing which would be
very cool if you go through all of it oh
this next season's gonna be [ __ ]
ridiculous what was lewis hamilton's
reaction like everything i'm googling is
basically he was just like he didn't
show up to the press conference
yeah he's upset you know i'm sure maybe
he thinks it's unfair but you could also
say that mercedes was [ __ ] like they
didn't play to win like they were like
oh they're just going to drive us out
and then we're just going to take the
safety car to the finish line they could
have they could have given up position
but prepared themselves just in case
and lewis
was like the couple times where he
thought he should have boxed or pitted
to change tires his team like strategy
wise they played it safe no let's leave
you on those tires they're durable
they'll go the distance but he was smart
enough and it's pretty a couple
particular moments to say like
why am i not boxing why am i not going
in there so
you can chalk it up to their strategy
uh was off but he was a gentleman in the
moment his dad was shaking hands with
max's dad like he did well i thought in
terms of that yeah well this would be a
chance if he wins next year to make this
a big asterisk like you can kind of
undercut the whole win i assume if you
win next year yeah doing next year and
you could be like the only reason i
don't have nine straight as this [ __ ]
bs decision yeah you can make his
verstappen's championship after his
championship basically an interesting
wrinkle to the whole race was that
max verstappen had won more races
throughout the year okay nine to louis's
eight so he was given the tiebreaker in
the event that they would end that race
with the same amount of points right now
how could they end a race with the same
amount of points well they would if
neither of them won any points right how
they do that let's say they crashed
right so
if max wanted to win yeah
just crash yeah and i think
i was watching a documentary was it
senna
i forget exactly what it is i watched a
documentary about a guy who did this
and basically like on the first turn
crashed into his rival and then took the
both of them out jeez up dude but that's
it that's guarantees the victory so if
max wanted it that bad yeah he could
have easily like driven really
aggressively pushed right lewis off the
side he crashed as well game over
he got it so it was in the bag for him
if he wants right now that's not maybe
the right way to win it but people have
won it in that way before